Take a look at this music
box for our first case study.
So I place it on the
glass of the scanner,
and it looks pretty good.
But as I look carefully.
Which I hope you will do when
you try this sort of stuff
with your work, a
couple of things
that I'm not thrilled with.
First of all, we're seeing
some writing on the barrel.
Looking closer, it appears
to be numbers and letters.
That's not great.
Our eyes go straight
to letters and numbers,
and they basically
attract our eye
and actually become a
distraction from the image,
as far as I'm concerned.
So I'm not happy with that.
I'm also not thrilled with
the positioning of the turning
mechanism.
Let's call it a stem.
Somehow it doesn't
feel composed properly.
So what I simply did, was I
played it a bit so the barrel
no longer shows the writing,
and I turned the stem
so that it landed in a
better composed image.
I've been thinking
about composition
all my professional
life, so see if you can
agree with me on this decision.
So I started thinking
about what difference
it would make if we changed
the orientation of the device
on the scanner.
Now remember the light
and sensors travel
only in one direction we
have no control over that.
So in this first image,
the barrel of the music box
is parallel to the light source.
In the next image I decided
to rotate the music box
90 degrees, that
is, perpendicular
to the light source.
Here's that image.
Take a look at the
two side by side
and observe the difference.
I'll let you think
about that for a bit.
So you see the first image,
made with the barrel oriented
parallel to the light source,
has a significant highlight.
Whereas the one
captured perpendicular
to the light source
has no highlight.
If I sat down for
a bit and tried
to anticipate all these
results by drawing arrows
from light sources and
reflections and all that,
I might have been able to
anticipate what the differences
would be in advance.
But I would prefer to just
discover it, experiment
with it, just as I hope you
will do with your own material.
And what it would look like if
I oriented the device about 45
degrees to the light source?
What do you think
will be the results?
Take a moment.
You can even stop the
video if you'd like to.
OK ready?
Here we go.
Nothing very important
here, I'm afraid.
But the point is to
experiment with your material.
Remember you don't have
control of your light source
with a scanner as you
will with your camera.
So at the very least,
take advantage of what
you do have control over.
And in this case, it's the
placement of your device.
Here you're seeing
this incredible animal
which is called a Euplectella,
which lives in the sea.
This is his skeleton,
made out of silica.
Now when you take
a careful look,
you can see that two
shrimp are living
within this guy in
what can be called
a symbiotic relationship.
Which is very
interesting, tangential,
but quite interesting.
So I put this
three-dimensional skeleton
on the flatbed scanner,
covered it with black velvet,
and took a very high res scan.
I think it was
something like one Gig
file, which is pretty high.
The black velvet becomes the
background of the image, right?
Now watch as we zoom
in to the image.
We start seeing this magnificent
structure that nature
is somehow able to produce.
Those fibers measure
about 50 microns.
So I'm quite
serious about seeing
things of very fine
structure, if in fact,
once again, you capture at
a high enough resolution.
Here's our final case study
for this particular tutorial.
It's about a 2 1/2
centimeter device,
which once again I
place on the scanner.
For this, I thought it
would be fun to show you
how I get some of these
things in the mail.
I made a quick image
with my phone camera
to show you what I start with,
and eventually wind up with.
I thought it would be
interesting for you.
You can do this.
You can see things that don't
look so great the beginning,
and imagine ways of creating
an image that is publishable.
Take a hard look at your
device as I'm doing here.
Try to look at it as if
you were looking at it
for the first time,
which I know is not easy,
but that's the trick.
You might even think about
focusing on getting a cover
image for your submission.
That's where my thinking
was on this device,
since the article was already
accepted for publication.
So here, the image I
made was about 374 megs.
And you can see as we
zoom in to the image
the nice detail in the device.
Again, when you capture at
a high enough resolution
on your scanner, you
can see these details.
So when you think
about cover designs,
for example, think about
cropping and formatting
for the cover.
In the end, it turned out
that for a cover submission
I did wind up using a camera
on the stereo microscope.
This is what I made
with that equipment
I thought I was getting more
clarity with the microscope.
But frankly when I compared
the two a few months later
as I record this tutorial, the
scan image looks pretty good.
And maybe I was in a
bit of overkill mode.
These are the kinds
of decisions you'll
have to make for your own work.
Maybe you have an opinion
about which is better.
Take a look.
By the way, in the end, in this
case, it didn't matter much.
We didn't get the cover.
But at least I was able to
show you another example.